[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy memorial day
everybody it's sort of a strange thing
to say happy memorial day because you
know we're out we're drinking beer we're
eating hot dogs we're at the beach maybe
but we are also remembering people who
gave their lives
to preserve our way of life our country
and our freedom
all of which i hate to remind you seem
more
under threat than perhaps ever before
you know in ideological ways in
some explicit physical ways people
burning down the country this sort of
thing
fortunately i am joined by one of the
most positive voices out there today i
mean this in his
demeanor but i also mean this in the
sort of things
that he is doing kirk cameron you may
know kirk from a whole variety of
different places of course
if you're a big fan of 80s sitcoms
perhaps you would know kirk
but also all the wonderful work he's
done well beyond acting
ever since then just a tremendous voice
in religious issues
in political issues kind enough to join
the show right now from what i can tell
just looking into the monitor
is the single most american place
on earth kirk where are you right now
hey michael so good to talk with you uh
i'm uh
i'm kind of it's a little kind of a fan
guy moment right now i'm an admirer
and so appreciate the work that you do
so thanks for for letting me
come to you from my backyard so that is
very kind
thank you i i've not tried to escape uh
the state yet
uh i'm still here in my backyard with my
flag waving and i've got a campfire
burning in my backyard
which is uh which has been pretty
typical of me for the last 100 days
uh in response to the first 100 days
of the current administration i i
decided to have a counter a counter 100
days
i loved when you when you announced this
because
one we're all we've all been a little
down i think you know
over the first days of the bind
administration but i liked your idea
that hey we don't
we don't need to just go along with this
we can we don't need to sit even and
complain we can
actually do something positive ourselves
right now we don't need to wait until
the next presidential election
or the one after that or the one after
that or the one after that so
i'm i'm there i think that waving the
flag
in your backyard is officially a hate
crime in the state of california now
but you're you've got the courage to do
it so so what's the mission what's the
plan
the hundred the kirk cameron hundred
days
so so i don't have the best plan in the
world but
i want to be a part of some plan and and
and we're we're here on memorial day and
it makes me think of my grandfather
uh my grandfather frank bowsmith who
just passed away and he was
a navy corpsman fighting with the
marines on the island of iwo jima
during world war ii he was a real hero
and he was a man of faith he was a man
of freedom he was a family man
and when i look at so many people making
promises so many talking heads talking
about
evidence and and and stuff that has been
coined
as hopium i i i then see none of this
stuff materialize and i said to myself
earlier this year wait a minute why
don't we
join together as we the people and come
up with our own first 100 days
and i said you know i i want to do
something
and history tells me that it's always a
minority
a a small group of people outnumbered
out uh outfunded usually persecuted
who pray to god join together and begin
doing things for honorable causes that
turns the
tide so i decided for 100 days in a row
i'm going to build a campfire in my
backyard and i'm going to invite people
on facebook live to join me
in my backyard to pray to play
music to sing songs of worship to god
and
go through a book that teaches us about
what made
america so free and prosperous and
blessed all these years
it was written by a friend of mine
called the american covenant the untold
story
and i'm not here to promote a book i'm
just saying that our forefathers had a
different idea
they didn't believe that hope flew in on
air force one
they said no we're a free people and our
hope comes
from the power of god working through
the hearts of moms and dads
and brothers and sisters and family
members and then we as people of
character and virtue take positions of
leadership
not only in our homes but in our
churches our communities our states
and the national government and it
starts with self-government
and so i've been teaching this for the
last 100 days in my backyard it's called
the american campfire revival
that's my plan kirk what you've said is
something very radical here you're
talking about american freedom
and you're saying it's way too radical
out there for california but it's
actually i think even a lot of
conservatives
don't quite appreciate what you're
saying because
what you're saying is that if we want to
restore american freedom
we need to get back to family we need to
get back to community we need to get
back to god
but i think the prevailing view right
now on the left and
all too often on the right is that true
freedom can only exist
when i shake off the shackles of my
family you know for instance
when you take away the necessity of
parental consent
for the way that your children are
educated or the sort of things your
children can do
the only way we can truly be free is
when we shack
shake off the shackles of god you know
this country it's a secular
country founded on a firm separation
between church and state and that that's
true freedom and you're positing
a totally different vision of liberty
than that
so who's right you know you know michael
as you were saying those words we need
to shake off the shackles of
family and true faith i could just smell
the fumes of horse manure coming through
my computer
as you're saying that because that
couldn't be further from the truth
you see these are those are the tenets
of marxism that you're talking about
these are the tenets that are designed
to divide a people
and make them easily conquerable and
what i've been learning
is that our forefathers and our
foremothers we're not just these
religious fuddy-duddies uh who were
trying to just
run away and and and and be by
themselves and create
this weird little religious community
they wanted a full
thriving flourishing human society
and they understood that it could not be
created and freedom could not be
achieved
from the top down where you had an
emperor or a king
or a queen or a czar or a shogun or a
prince
who would who would give you everything
you need and allow you to have freedom
it came from the inside when you're when
your own
heart was liberated from uh
from pride and selfishness and you began
to love god
and you began to love your neighbor and
you governed yourself
see george washington and abraham
lincoln and the pilgrims and our
founders
they said no it's it's it's counter
intuitive
to to what you see in other kingdoms the
kingdom
that is characterized by freedom and
blessing begins when
you begin to govern your own self and
then as a self-governing
mom and dad you can then govern your
family and your children
and then children begin to grow up and
go into the world and heavenize
the earth as they implement these
principles of integrity and
honesty and truth and compassion and
love and mercy
and that's the inside out bottom-up
strategy
that built america and allows us to have
limited small government
if we don't govern ourselves they said
we'll have no choice
but to have someone from outside and up
high
come and and beat us back into
uh obedience and and if we don't
voluntarily submit to things like the
ten commandments
then we will be ruled by the ten
thousand commandments of the tyrants
and and i see that happening right now
and so i'm trying to call people back to
genuine revival that begins in the heart
and in the home
kirk how did you get so smart i mean
this and not as flattery i don't i'm not
being polite no
what you're describing here you're
talking about american history
and you're saying that the the popular
view on the left but
all too often on the right that our our
founding fathers were atheists
or total secularists that that's not
true obviously you're right that america
was founded in this flourishing
you're getting the whiff again you know
this
this uh historical anti-historical idea
that that our country was founded to be
this secular country rather than
a shining city upon a hill and from a
model of christian charity one of the
earliest
american speeches you're you're knocking
down that idea
you you're recognizing the philosophical
distinction
between liberty and licentiousness which
all too often is totally conflated but
but you recognize they're not the same
thing they're actually opposite things
i i'm not joking when i say you
you are expressing a much wiser truer
opinion
than the vast majority of of american
commentators on this even
even many on the right how how did that
happen well
you're right there there are so many
people on the right on the left who are
brilliant and far smarter than i am
um but i'm seeing that that much of it's
not working a lot of it feels like a hot
a bunch of hot air to me and i say wait
a minute wait a minute
in a very short amount of time history
shows us that america became one of the
pinnacle nations in the world
and guys like alex de tocqueville and
others came over and said what's the
secret of the success of this this new
nation
and it's not in their military and it's
not in their it's not in their their
their
economy and it's not in all of these
places you typically want to find it
you know what their churches have
pulpits
that are on fire with the gospel and
people's hearts were being transformed
and they
wanted to do the right thing without
having to be told
and when that begins to happen all of a
sudden
it's like the lion king it's it's i it
reminds me of when simba
uh who believed the lie that he had
murdered his father mufasa
runs out into the wilderness loses track
of his identity and then
rafiki goes out there and says simba
you've forgotten who you are
and he taken to the pool of water and he
sees a reflection of his father and he
hears the voice
of mufasa in the sky and says simba
remember who you are
you are the rightful son you are the
king
and he runs back and scar sees him and
who does he think he sees
he thinks he sees his father mufasa
and then he fights him simba wins
regains his place as the king and all of
life
comes back into the pride lands and
darkness and the shadows begin to flee
i think we as americans have have
similarly forgotten who we
are we come from a long line of freedom
fighters
who are not looking for riots and
lawlessness
but we're the army of compassion who is
looking to bring healing to a broken
nation who's so woke that they they've
fallen asleep to what really brings
freedom and truth and healing to us
and if we will we'll move from the heart
and get back to these essential
principles
uh which by the way i've tried to uh uh
encapsulate with something that i've
made available
called the pledge to renew the american
covenant
most people don't even know that we had
such a thing called the american
covenant
and and these are sacred promises made
by our forefathers
to god and to one another and and and it
begins with stuff like this we affirm as
a family
to uh to do these things and it talks
about the personal level the family
level
the church level and this the civic
level
and if we'll come back to these things i
believe we'll begin to see life coming
back into
uh this land of promise that we've
inherited i think you're right and i
love
the mufasa analogy remember who you
are and you're probably uniquely
qualified to perceive this sort of thing
as a storyteller which is we have these
national stories and these national
stories
tell us about our identity the way we
understand our past
is going to influence how we behave in
the present and what our country is
going to look like in the future so
right now
there's a battle over american history
you've got the traditional understanding
which this is a good country
founded on good principles with good
people you know got some problems we're
all broken this is a fallen world but
it's generally a good place and we like
that
and then there's the 1619 project
version which is
in their own words a reframing of
american history
they lied about some facts there too but
they're just gonna shift the frame like
you're moving the camera
and they're gonna present this picture
of america as intrinsically
evil and wrong and we have to be very
sorry and ashamed of it
so how how do we reclaim the story i
mean what is what is the story that
we're telling
well one of the ways that i'm doing that
is by going to more reliable sources
than the 1619 project or your you know
your typical social media news feed
um and it's hard to find trusted sources
now and so
um again the one that i'm i'm actually
uh spent 100 days of my life
in a row uh traveling across the country
and changing my flight schedule so that
i could have a campfire
at a hotel or a friend's house or my own
backyard is this book called the
american covenant
um i i hesitate to even show it up
because i don't want you to think i'm
i'm trying to
to push this but what it does is it goes
back to
information that people don't hear
anymore and it's talking
uh and quoting from people who
understand history
and and see the world differently that
history truly is
his story his story and that
there is the unseen hero in the events
of the world
that are being played out on the stage
of earth and michael i think you and i
and everybody else who's alive today
have been placed on this stage
to play a strategic role we're not the
main character but we're supporting
characters of the one who's working all
things together for good
and i want to be wise i want to play my
part
and that's the way our founders and
forefathers and mothers
understood time in history
let's let's play our role correctly
shakespeare said that as well
all the world is a stage and if we see
this world as a narrative
that has been authored by the most
benevolent
being in the universe then we can have
hope
and we can find courage to do the right
thing against all odds
knowing that it will turn around and it
will be good in the end even if we're
not here to see it
maybe my kids will and that's worth it
enough for me to put all i have into it
what an important point when you look at
american history and you look at all the
great characters george washington
governor bradford all lincoln all these
people
to to recognize the most important
character
who is god and you you see the hand of
providence i was going to say the unseen
hand of providence but actually you can
you can really see it the odds that when
the mayflower lands at plymouth harbor
they get delayed there's all sorts of
sabotage in the old world
they finally make it here they're blown
hundreds of miles off course they land
at some random spot
and out of the woods pops the two
indians on the entire continent
who speak english one of whom
esquanto lived in london and was talking
to the the pilgrims about the streets of
london
because he had been captured he was
brought over there he was freed
probably freed by catholic monks brought
then to
london comes back on another ship the
odds of this happening just by random
chance
are virtually nothing and yet this is
the
the first moment that allows these
pilgrims basically not to just get
totally wiped out on their first winter
in the new world
what are the odds of that i think
we don't i i don't think we need to play
the odds you you know as well as i do
that the hand of providence is
is uh is behind all things and i love
the story of the pilgrims i i
i think we can go back there and learn
so much for them from them
um in fact one of the things that i
thought was so fascinating is that when
they first landed
they actually landed in a place that
they thought was the mainland but it
wasn't it was a little island off the
coast of the mainland and i actually
went there in a little
private little boat and there there they
realized it was the sabbath day when
they landed and so they didn't
want to do anything for fear that they
would do something that might offend the
god of providence that had brought them
all the way across the atlantic in a
little wine ship
that had been designed only to go port
to port in england the mast had broken
they for sure thought they were going to
sing and so they spent the day
praying and reading scripture on a big
boulder they called
they called um pulpit rock and and again
this is the kind of
of of wholehearted faith that they had
and they they switched from
a socialistic framework in the way that
they did business
to a free uh capitalistic mindset
and and everybody had their own piece of
land and they if they didn't work they
didn't eat
and and and they changed things around
to fit the principles in scripture
and they began to prosper they began to
give thanks
that's where we get thanksgiving from uh
those those first couple of
of uh falls and winter with the pilgrims
where half of them died
at one point there were six people who
were taking care of the rest of them who
were still living in the winter
most of them women and some of them just
laying on top of their children
dead so that they could keep their
children alive this is the kind of
character that we need to see in america
again and i'm hoping that
all of this from the pandemic to the
economy
to the political things we see happening
wakes us up and
shakes us up and that character and
virtue and faith rise to the top
and these i don't think we're without a
revival these things are connected i'm
glad you brought up the point about the
early socialism of the
of the pilgrims because very often the
left writes this off as just some kind
of
shallow conservative talking point it's
not just some talking point governor
bradford writes about this
in detail that's right you know they
hation yes they did and finally they
instituted a bit more private property a
bit more private responsibility and what
happens
they all start to flourish and they they
tie in together this economic component
with the political component and then
what's most important is the religious
component you know
andrew breitbart the patron saint of
hollywood conservatives he
famously said politics is downstream of
culture and uh
you know this is not to deny that
politics influences culture too
but certainly we can say culture is
downstream of
religion cult and culture come from the
same root word so how do we revive the
country
so michael that's such a great point in
plymouth massachusetts i don't know if
you've ever seen this
but there is there is a giant monument
it is a hundred and
i'm sorry it's 88 feet tall it's um i
think
about 180 tons of solid granite and it's
called the national monument to the
forefathers it's the largest granite
monument in america and it's hidden in a
forest
on top of a hill in plymouth
massachusetts if you have a chance to go
there i highly recommend it because
it is the the the forefathers recipe for
how to sustain
freedom and prosperity in america
and and if you look at it uh you know if
if my cup here
is is that monument uh you would come up
to about this
high on top of the monument and the top
of it is
faith and faith then expresses herself
to all areas of life morality law
education resulting in liberty and so
you're right it begins with faith
and an internal change of the heart uh
this isn't
uh something that politicians are making
up this is something that we can find in
in the you know 4 000 year old
principles found in the judeo-christian
scriptures this is the principles that
the ancient hebrew republic
under moses uh flourished before they
got their kings
this was about representative government
this is about a division of powers
this is all about self-government these
are the kinds of things our founders
understood
they applied it and it worked and we can
get back to it well i hope we can kirk
but
all this talk this has been way too
positive and hopeful for a conservative
radio show so i need to bring in a
little bit of pessimism here
that's it let's shoot let's let's fire
shots at the balloon
well here is the big problem recent
polls show
every year fewer and fewer people are
going to church fewer and fewer people
are identifying with religion
the fastest growing religious group in
america it's called the nuns and i'm not
talking about cute little old ladies and
habits i'm talking about
n-o-n-e people who have no religious
affiliation
so how are we supposed to get an
american revival when everyone's
fleeing church i i wouldn't worry about
that uh
the solution is not sitting here and
crying in our in our in our
chick-fil-a soup uh as christians okay
the solution
is to understand uh you know if you look
at the stock market
you can say oh we're in a downturn we're
in a downturn uh
well but but you look at the trajectory
over time
uh the the christian faith has been
flourishing
over time go back a thousand years where
was culture and life and
and living as a person of faith better
or worse now than it was back then
i wouldn't want to be alive during the
roman empire when people were being
thrown to the lions and burned at the
stake
we have more freedom now and we are are
actually winning
in the courts at the supreme court level
and at state levels on religious cases
and we're about to have more freedom
than we have had uh in a generation
because i believe people are waking up
at the same time i think it's good to to
separate the sheep from the goats and
the wheat from the chaff
i think it's good to shake the place out
and find out
who is really in this to win this and
who's really playing church for the sake
of uh
you know keeping a job or uh collecting
tithe money or or looking good to your
friends
um i'm not inviting persecution
but if we see challenges come i say
the kite that's really anchored with a
good strong string
is gonna fly higher the stronger the
winds
a very good point the the blood of the
martyr is seeded to the church
and sure i'm sort of hoping we don't get
thrown to lions or anything but a little
bit of
of trial of course can be spiritually
quite edifying and that that's true on
the national level
too so i'm glad you've given me hope
again all right
i'm shaking off that pessimism for now
we're looking back
and we're you know we're trying to find
our national future
in in those the the faith of our
founders
and uh trying to recover some of that
but
once now we've dealt with the church
issue what about the education issue
students are simply not being exposed to
this stuff there was a survey that came
out now it was 14 years ago this is a
2007 survey
imagine how much worse it is today it
was all the top colleges in america
they surveyed it was on civics and
government and
history in the united states graduating
seniors
did worse on the test than incoming
freshmen
the students had gotten more ignorant
the longer that they were in the schools
and and the question i mean i mean the
the question i guess is obvious to the
answer is obvious
you know when we vacate uh the
responsibility we abdicate the
responsibility
of training our children up in the way
that they should go we shouldn't be
surprised
when they come out the other side of the
educational system uh
without the results that we're hoping
for i think a friend of mine named vody
backham said
if you send your children to caesar
to be educated don't be surprised if
they come back romans
and that's true it's a discipleship
program for 12 years
through high school and then an advanced
discipleship program as we go into
higher education
and you know that's why i come back to
well what's the right thing
i'm not even looking to the left i'm not
even looking to the right
i think the choice as ronald reagan once
put it is either up or down
we either go up to the eternal rules of
right and the principles that are found
in the scriptures
that history show produce maximum human
flourishing
uh or we go down to the ash heap of
totalitarianism
and i think that what we need to do is
say wow
educating our children is a sacred
responsibility i'm not going to just
hand it off to somebody else it doesn't
mean i have to be a math teacher and a
science teacher
and a music teacher but what it does
mean is i can read good books
i can find good sources of information
and i as a parent
understand that that little heart that
little soul that little mind
has been placed in my hands by god and
i'm gonna lead their educational path
and put them in the presence of good
people not just
hand them over to a government
babysitter where they're going to
undermine
everything that i want my children to
believe and to embrace
we've got to recapture education i think
that's where we went wrong
40 50 years ago and that's the biggest
single mistake that we've made we've got
to recapture education
of course but kirk what do you say to
people who say you know listen
i'm glad for you kirk that you've got
this clear sense of right and wrong and
good and bad and true and false and
beautiful and ugly i'm glad you got that
but that's just
your opinion man to quote the dude
lebowski
and maybe i've got my opinion of right
and wrong it's totally different and
look you've got your preferences and
i've got my preferences and
and if you try to appeal to some eternal
moral authority why
you're just a theocratic authoritarian
i don't know they'll find lots of
adjectives to call you what do you say
to those people who say
i i i it is very important for us to
indoctrinate children
in say drag queen story hour but you
need to keep your bible out of our
schools
no i i would say actually your narrative
is is actually backwards the reality is
is that the truth of a good and kind and
loving and just god
uh uh is obvious the evidence is all
around you through what he has made
and through the scriptures that he's uh
left for us here and through the
evidence of the transformed life
of those who have i've come to know him
know him and walk with him
you're actually trying to indoctrinate
a country uh out of the truth and
into your pagan ideas that always
produce
death and despair it always produces
bondage rather than freedom
so if you want to make up this narrative
that you
evolved out of the slime that we are
just a happy accident
where we are over arching worms that uh
there was no design in mind
for uh the birth of my child and your
nervous system and your muscular system
and your skeletal system
and all of the other wonders and
miracles found throughout nature
you you can keep your head in the sand
and you can believe your happy fairy
tale
that really is designed to get you off
the hook morally
and and try to absorb all of you of any
accountability
but i would rather stick with the
time-tested method that has produced
the greatest nations on earth and
maximum human flourishing and actually
allows you
to believe those crazy things in this
country without being put into prison
because we believe you were made in the
image of god too and so
therefore i'm going to treat you just as
kindly as i would like you to treat me
even though you're crazy i love that
answer
you know i've noticed from the people
who insist
there's no such thing as grace or sin
there's no such thing as right or wrong
it's all just a
an accident of pistons firing off in our
head i i always look at them
to quote another line from the board and
say the lady doth protest too much
methinks
these people seem sometimes a little
wrecked with guilt
they don't seem quite so certain of what
they're what they're putting out there
yeah we have just this wonderful country
and and and i think that we've been
we've been um living off the fumes
of faith that our forefathers and four
mothers
um had and we need to get back to these
principles because
uh the truth is if there are other
principles that produce more
freedom more flourishing uh more
opportunity
for for all people by all means please
go live there
go there yeah and and see what that's
like why is it that everyone's breaking
the law to come here
um and and then they're wanting to then
vote for
principles and policies that are going
to take this country
to become more like the place you just
escaped from yeah that just doesn't make
sense to me
and i can tell you and and those who
have studied history know
that the best places to live are in the
places where people
genuinely love god and genuinely love
their neighbor
and that requires a change of heart and
those who want to use religion to abuse
people and there's been lots of examples
of that in the past even in our country
they that needs to be thrown into the
trash heap just like all the other false
ideas and we need to get back to
something that's
true and uh and praiseworthy and
honorable
uh and that's what i'm trying to be
about
yeah you know i notice a lot of people
who prattle on about humanity and
humanity and all this they go on and on
and on
but they they don't seem to care very
much about their fellow humans
you know and people who say we we need
to uh you know totally transform america
they don't seem to like their countrymen
very much and so i think what you're
saying is so true the countries
that are the freest the most flourishing
the most pleasant to live in
are the ones that recognize god that
love god
and that love their neighbors and love
their countrymen kirk i've done my best
to bring in some typical conservative
pessimism here
and you have thwarted me at every turn
i'm leaving this conversation hopeful
and
you're doing the thing you're sitting
there you got a nice campfire
a fluttering waving american flag and
you know looking back on our country and
bringing up wonderful memories
on memorial day no better way to
celebrate than that
well i i'm encouraged by you i'm
encouraged by the daily wire i'm
encouraged by
uh the guy that i just bumped into in
the grocery store
at trader joe's as i was getting some
sausage for dinner tonight
and uh you know he he had a he had an
american flag on his shirt he looked at
me i didn't have a mask on either did he
and he said oh my goodness
look at this another free human
and he said this is wonderful and he
said remember
what you allow will continue and uh
we had a great conversation and those
kinds of things inspire me
to to want a lovingly and courageously
stand for the right stuff just like
you're doing thank you
kirk you you have inspired me seriously
i mean
you've just done really great work i've
now got to go out and get the american
covenant by the way i know
you said you don't want to plug the book
but now i certainly do the american
covenant got to go order it
um kirk keep doing what you're doing man
it's just it's so uh it's such great
work
it's so important and you've even you've
even managed to give some hope
to a curmudgeonly conservative maybe
many of us out there today thank you
kirk cameron everybody thanks so much
for coming on
all right michael great talking with you
thank you
you